Japan is set to unveil a hotel that
replaces room keys with facial
recognition and replaces humans with
robots and researchers in Chile recently
recorded The Velvet worm shooting a
sticky web like spider-man
it's a glue cannon Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow the digital brain
library is slicing up and preserving
human brains based in San Diego this
brain Bank not only slices human brains
into micron thin pieces but also
digitizes them at extremely high
resolutions and this digital archive
will be used to create the Google Earth
of the human brain work of water has
developed a bamboo tower that collects
water from the air designed for rural
communities with limited access to
potable water the work at our stores
water from rain Dew and fog the tower
looks to be cheaper than current water
relief options so the hope is that it
will give rural villages stable access
to water the Lucid pipe power system is
designed to generate electricity with
the help of your sewage by installing
turbines into existing water lines the
Lucid pipe generates clean energy by
utilizing the water flow that's
happening underground anyway
unlike solar and wind energy isn't
dependent upon weather as it takes
advantage of day-to-day human activity
this is a self fueled liquid metal motor
the drop of metal alloy is suspended in
a solution of sodium hydroxide and is
fueled by a flake of aluminum and this
team is literally trying to make
intelligent robots that can change shape
so yeah
researchers at University of California
Berkeley have met to grow human heart
cells on a computer chip they're grown
from stem cells and surrounded by micro
fluid channels which supply them with
nutrients and drugs the heart cells
could be modified to model human genetic
diseases and could eliminate the need
for animal testing of drugs new jersey
is building the world's largest indoor
vertical farm it's currently under
construction and plans to grow 2 million
pounds of food each year without soil it
will use colored LEDs and nutrient-rich
liquid solutions to grow leafy greens as
as herbs and spices and represents a
huge step in urban farming the voxel 8
can 3d print electronics by utilizing an
ink that's over 5000 times more
conductive than current conductive paste
and filaments the device can print
electronic parts that were previously
impossible to make the prayer start
shipping in late 2015 but you can
pre-order them now so you can start
designing your 3d printed drone
researchers at MIT have developed a new
way to stimulate brain tissue with
magnets by injecting magnetic iron oxide
particles into the brain and then
exposing them to an alternating magnetic
field of particles heat up and stimulate
their surrounding brain tissue
this new method could revolutionize the
way neurological diseases like
Parkinson's are treated and the
procedure is Wireless non-invasive and
can be remote control h plus plus is
developing interactive holographic
systems the Hollis will be a home
appliance for interactive holographic
games and apps and the magic room will
be a virtual interactive play space for
children
finally here's the beta version of taiga
one of the many social robots being
developed by the personal robots group
I'm going to leave you with a robot that
can balance on one foot while
interacting with humans and as always
thanks for watching